einfach entspannt auf der eigenen
terrasse eine rauchen für die adobe in
dortmund ist dass nicht mehr möglichst
schon wieder kurz vor zwölf jetzt aber
mal schnell die letzten züge sonst droht
der knast das dortmunder landgericht hat
herrn doofe nebst gattin dazu verurteilt
im heimischen garten nur nach
stundenplan zu rauchen
tabakkonsum ist seither nur noch in drei
stunden takt legal ansonsten strengstens
verboten auf uns nicht von 9 bis 12 uhr
und das auch noch in zürich dürften nach
dem aufstehen dürfen wieder stören wir
den nutzen des kunden brauchen
der rauch stört die nachbarn aber erst
seitdem die dosis ein dach über ihrer
terrasse installiert haben ein
wundersames dach das den qualm auf
magische weise umleitet und heraus so
wie es in familien wirken und wollen
vorn rüber runterlaufen auf deren
terrasse beschrieb ihn tiefer liegt und
mit den hausrat im keller oder im fluss
für winzer seit drei jahren beschäftigen
dobes dach und dessen rauch strömungen
die gerichte
während das amtsgericht keine
belästigung der nachbarn fest stellte
urteilte das landgericht ja es stinkt
und verordnete den strafbewehrten rauch
plan
seither drohen den dobes geldstrafen von
bis zu 250.000 euro oder gar sechs
monate gefängnis für außerplanmäßiges
qualmen in der eigenen garten idylle und
hier ganz hinten im garten und da hoffe
ich auch nicht aus wir dürfen sie nicht
auch mal im garten nicht ganz so
greulich nicht
warum oktober festgelegt hat und wie
nachbarn so gefreut haben die nachbarn
wollen übrigens vor der kamera nicht
über den zigaretten kleinkrieg reden
in dortmund ist der streit stadtgespräch
unter rauchern und nichtrauchern
eigentlich wollte man sich einfach mal
um sich selbst kümmern weil man sich ja
gibt im nachbar haushalt auch irgendwas
was diejenigen stört und damit nicht
gesagt und worten geht halten dann soll
man nicht mehr tun und deswegen machen
zu hause ab dann weil man rauchen das
ist ein bisschen privatsphäre qualm hin
qualm her
der rechtsanwalt der dorfes kann die
argumentation der richter nicht
nachvollziehen
hier werden zwei grundrechtspositionen
ja auch umstritten wie wir gestritten
einmal das gesundheitliche recht was die
nachbarn behaupten sie werden
beeinträchtigt und das rechte auge auf
dem grundstück ihrem eigentum ist dieses
eigentum zu machen grundsätzlich das
sind auch die nachbarn vertreten wohl
die meinung vieler deutscher denn
nichtrauchen liegt im trend
so mancher fordert noch stärkeren
nichtraucherschutz
dabei wird schon jetzt restriktiv mit
rauchern umgegangen in kneipen büros und
flughäfen drängen sie sich in den
ausgewiesenen zonen das rauchen im
privatbereich bleibt strittig
so wie später mal grün
denschlag 2 ist beginnt zwar das
rauchverbot aber nur für die dosis heißt
es zigarette aus logisch ist das nicht
aber laut richterspruch dass sich hier
jeder gast rund um die uhr die lunge aus
dem hals qualmen auch der reporter und
herr dobel guckt zu nachteil
kein problem in dortmund ist qualm und
qualm eben längst nicht dasselbe